we tend to think of the hamburger as a
quintessentially American invention the
fastest of fast food and a relatively
recent innovation but the idea of
grinding up leftover meat and forming it
into a handy patty goes back hundreds of
years the Romans were the first to write
their version down in the shape of its
akia omen tartar a mixture of a minced
pork wine pepper and garam the new mommy
rich fish sauce ubiquitous in Roman
cuisine each was wrapped in caul fat
the delicate tasteless inner lining of
the thorax of cows sheep and pigs
this was high-end cookery and it
survived the collapse of the Roman
Empire with these proto burgers finding
their way into medieval recipe
collections under various names
there were resolves patties and pomp
ease and they could be flat or round
more like modern meatballs they could
also contain anything from fish to meat
and occasionally fruit and vegetables
variations on the theme were also found
in the Middle East and beyond some of
which such as kebabs were brought back
by travellers to join the European
repertoire by around 1700 the fried
flavoured minced meat concept had become
established as part of the British
culinary repertoire as oval or round
balls they were very popular for
garnishing large spectacular dishes such
as roast meats
the Georgians also came up with a thing
called the Hamburg sausage which was
based on minced beef and isn't a million
miles distant in flavor from its
eventual successor and they decided to
use tomatoes to make catsup lady wood
ketchup another fundamental element of
the modern dish by the end of the 19th
century all of the elements were in
place but it was in the US that they
finally came together by the 1870s
American restaurants were serving
Hamburg steaks named after the German
port from where high-quality beef was
shipped across the world this version
was a dish of fried flushing meatballs
though made from offcuts from the more
prized and expensive actual steaks by
now the mincing machine had been
invented making it easier than ever
before to turn bits of random meat into
tasty and cheap meals by the 1890s the
flat meatballs were being served in
bread rolls to hungry workers at factory
gates across the US with relation
optional addition and pickles on one
side the hamburger state was shortened
to the simple hamburger and a classic
was born of course it could have simply
stayed as an urban curiosity and died
out like other street food such as dried
apples and pickled oyster
but it was very practical very easy and
very popular in 1921 the White Castle
fast food chain was founded marketing
Barre hamburgers as pure a hygienic li
produced something somewhat lacking from
the average street version by the nicely
30s hamburgers had become simpler
burgers and White Castle had competition
from the first wimpy and then McDonald's
in 1954 the first wimpy reached the UK
tucked into a Lyons Corner House
injecting some american and glamour into
a britain just released from rationing
they were initially served on a nice
plate with knife and fork things change
rapidly however and burgers gained a
dual purpose as a cheap forgettable
takeout and barbecue fodder in 2013 the
uk's horse meat scandal revealed just
how much bad burgers relied on cheap off
cuts and filler to keep the price down
and posh burgers boomed along with the
brioche bun and homemade sources
worldwide despite slowly decreasing beef
consumption in the West burger
consumption is going up and while
Australia the UK in the u.s. lead the
pack France and washer are catching up
look on burger anyone thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon